and because of what they did the  severity of the FBI coming in raiding  Mar-A-Lago  were they looking for the Hillary  Clinton emails that were deleted but  they are around someplace so Trump is  that he's making a good observation  saying they obviously didn't go after  Hillary this way and Hillary had not  only did she have more urgent documents  that were contemporary documents they  were documents while she was Secretary  of State not documents from the past  when she was in office as was the case  with Trump but furthermore he's saying  Hillary did not have this ultimate right  to declassify stuff and I as president  did and I didn't have to follow a  procedure and I could declassify it with  a magic wand I could declassify it by  saying these are Declassified I could  declassify documents simply by thinking  these documents are Declassified  and so what people are going to hear is  ah there's Trump's hyperbole again  there's Mr Trump Mr exaggerator  he's right  he's right